how much time and energy should
filmmakers pay attention to film critics
review that's a great question I don't
think I've ever been asked that question
before how much time should filmmakers
and directors pay attention to the
critics um as much as doesn't drive them
insane I don't know I've seen some
filmmakers you can can't handle one bad
review and it just rips their hair out
I've seen other filmmakers who want to
read every review good bad other
whatever from my experience recently as
a producer on a movie at tribeca seeing
the reviews come in was really
interesting and I actually found it
helpful and I enjoyed it maybe because I
am a critic on some level but also just
because I thought a lot of the criticism
when the film was true and so I didn't I
was I was resentful towards the person
who wrote the review because it came
from an honest place and it came from a
respectful place and intelligent a lot
of the things they didn't like about our
film I understood and I thought were
problematic about our movie too so I
think any filmmaker who is comfortable
enough in their own work and proud
enough of their own work I'm insanely
proud of the movie reproduce it's called
Alakazam short documentary about Sal
Masekela and his father hugh masekela
Sal's been a mentor and a dear friend of
mine over the years i'm proud that we
were able to tell his story and premiere
in a place i tribeca grew up in New York
it was an amazing experience to be there
one negative review is not going to take
that away from me so I could read the
reviews on it and I'm interested in
people's feedback on the film cause like
we said earlier everyone coming up to
you and being like it was great I loved
it doesn't it doesn't really mean
anything to you after a while there's a
funny part about that in the Woody Allen
documentary that came out last year
where he's at a movie premiere and
everyone's coming up to him and says all
of Germany loves you and he's sitting
there goes really all Germany loves me
well I got funny how things have come
around um but I I think you have to like
a lot of the themes a lot of the things
you've been talking about today you
can't have to know yourself and have a
good under
standing of how you're going to react to
things and if one negative review is
going to throw you off the deep end and
send you into a downward spiral of shame
then don't read reviews probably um I
because because what can happen then is
that you lose sight of how you want to
tell stories and I think that would be
real disservice if some one person
didn't like your review your your movie
and then now you were changing up your
movies the way you make movies your
style that sucks I mean that happened to
me when people were attacking the way I
was reviewing movies and just living my
life on some level if I had really
gotten caught up and all that
on the internet about me I would have
gotten to a place where I couldn't do
what I do so I kind of had to understand
that it was there read it have a laugh
at it but be confident myself to
understand that okay I'm going to
continue on the path that I know my
heart my gut is true so I would say the
same thing to filmmakers that kind of
have a good sense of yourself and and if
the feedback it negatively puts you in a
weird place then maybe you shouldn't do
it but also on the flip side and I think
what's harder to do is to get all the
feedback that comes in when it's
insanely positive not let that put you
up in a certain place you know if you
make a movie that everybody's just
raving about and they love and they're
moved by and it gets all these awards
that could probably turn some people
into a crazy person into an into
a difficult person but if you can I
don't know except that appreciate it
feel good about it feel validated by it
on some level but then kind of move it
aside and get back to work look at some
point Tom Hooper you know I Best
Director wins for King's Speech King's
Speech gets all his awards I bet you on
his next movie he has the same type of
button security but anxiousness and
stress and fortitude that he did while
making the King's Speech I would imagine
so and he wants to challenge himself and
put himself out there that's what makes
him a great filmmaker
but if someone is going to praise you
and you're just going to sit back and
coast then you shouldn't really read
those reviews either I think so I know
as an indie filmmaker I think it is
important though to have a relationship
with the people who are watching your
movies so the most successful indie
filmmakers build a cult following they
build a loyal following from Morgan
Spurlock's of Tyler Perry to Michael
Moore to when you how to spike lee i
mean they there when you're an indie
filmmaker you need to know your audience
is and who's going to gravitate towards
your movie and how to reach them so I
think it's really important you know to
have a relationship with the critics and
the journalists were covering your
movies because they're your lifeblood
they're the ones who are getting it out
there you don't have a partnership with
McDonald's to have your indie film on
coke cups you know you don't have your
film on billboards everywhere you need
the critics the word of mouth good bad
other or whatever to get people talking
about your movie so I think it would be
a real disservice if any indie filmmaker
just dismissed the media and what people
were saying about their movies I think
they would ultimately end up rated
ultimately end up partying their career
on some level
you